well you know when there's so much good
holiday cooking going on in the kitchen
no doubt your furry family members are
sitting there standing there begging for
a taste too but you know not everything
on the people menu for your thanksgiving
dinner is good for your dog or cat to
eat it may even be dangerous for them so
we've put together a list of
thanksgiving favorites you can share
with fido and those that are a definite
no-no so here we go let's start with the
yummy and safe foods to share in
moderation most healthy foods for us are
also nutritious for our pets
according to the american kennel club
and also a variety of veterinarians
here's the safe list
cooked turkey breast meat now the the
dark meat is is fattier and please no
bones or skin skin has the seasoning in
it and it's fatty for your pets green
beans carrots peas those are really good
raw or cooked but without seasoning so
you don't want all those spices and
seasonings in there cooked sweet or
russet potatoes but not the mashed
potatoes with the butter spices or sour
cream sweet potatoes are actually really
good for your pet good source of
vitamins and fiber raw apple pieces
without the core in the seeds because
those can be harmful and pumpkin raw or
canned not the pie filling pumpkin with
the spices but pumpkin is also a really
good source of fiber for your dog and if
your cat will eat it now there are the
foods that you should spare your pets
that can cause anything from upset
stomach or diarrhea to being even toxic
or even deadly for your dogs and or your
cats fats and oils and that includes
gravies rich gravies
bones meat skin and remember strings
that tie up the turkey or a roast
sometimes they can get caught in a piece
of meat and if you feed that to your pet
that can be digested and sometimes
caught in their intestines onions garlic
chives and leeks we may think they're
really yummy but they're bad for your
pets grapes and
grapes and raisins very toxic
chocolate is really terrible for dogs
very toxic and xylitol that's artificial
sweetener in desserts and baked items
can also be very harmful to an animal's
liver and alcohol and raw eggs those are
two very unhealthy we do we need to say
alcohol no alcohol for your pets but raw
eggs have can have salmonella yeah of
course and so you know those are just
things to think about and also too just
talk to your dinner guests and say look
you know these are the things that you
can slip them these are absolute no-nos
please and also make sure to take out
the trash or tie up the trash yeah
because those little noses can sniff out
all those table scraps that have been
thrown away in the trash can when you're
not looking they're gonna get into them
like christmas vacation and the dog when
i was a kid we used to just put the dogs
outside
while we ate our so they would like
chase the squirrels around and stuff for
a couple of hours and then we bring them
inside when we're done that works here
because we have decent weather yes yeah
if you're going to be outside hey maybe
you could eat outside today what do you
think thanksgiving outside maybe if you
have one of those heaters
okay